ça c'est beau dans un champ de
Saint-Félix de kenzee un sauvetage de
légumes est en cours
parmi les rescapés des caisses et des
caisses de carottes des légumes bio
parfaitement bons qui rendu à ce temps
ci de l'année serait laissé au chat
aujourd'hui on a reçu des glaneurs donc
plusieurs personnes qui ont porté main
forte avenir récolter les légumes que
j'ai en trop
[Musique]
les glaneurs et les glaneuses ce sont
des bénévoles qui viennent cueillir
gratuitement en échange d'une part de la
cueillette des Chantal qui m'a contacté
quand elle a commencé son organisme qui
cherchait des fermes à pouvoir aller
glaner puis j'avais jamais entendu
parler de ça donc vraiment expliqué
comment ça marchait puis je trouvais ça
une super idée
Chantal c'est la coordonnées après avec
sa brigade de glaneur elle vient prêter
main forte au maraîchers cueille et
transforme par la suite une partie de la
récolte nous c'est principalement des
agriculteurs bio qu'on fait par contre
les bio c'est tout fait à la main puis
bon avec le manque de main d'oeuvre
souvent ça fait leur affaire donc on
arrive à cueille tout pour après ça on
fait justement une séparation entre les
déclassés les beaux qui peuvent mettre
au marché en fin de session comme ça on
perd nos stagiaires puis mais les
produits sortent toujours donc ça nous
prend quand même des bras donc on va
sauver du temps puis on partage nos
légumes en échange parce que c'est
parfait
glaner c'est ramasser les restes d'une
récolte qui serait restée au champ c'est
une pratique répandue en Europe depuis
des siècles et illustré dans le célèbre
tableau de Jean-François Millet
en France c'est un droit et quiconque
peut glaner à condition de respecter les
règles en le faisant après la récolte à
la main et en plein jour ici on partage
en trois par la cueillettes le premier
tiers il va rester au producteurs on va
prioriser les beaux on va laisser les
beaux pour qu'ils refassent la clientèle
va être partagée entre les cueilleurs
donc si on a dit que hier ils vont avoir
un dixième du tiers qui peut être des
très grosses quantités et il va avoir le
dernier tiers qui revient l'organisme
meilleur après qui elle va redonner à
d'autres organismes
on va faire le partage vous allez avoir
9 livres de carottes de chacun ça c'est
complètement gratuitement pour pour les
gaillards
cueillette c'est des légumes que j'ai de
trop donc c'est le je vais finir par les
perdre en bout de ligne ça a pas été
trop long votre
shader avec carottes c'est juste du
bonheur donc c'est sûr que en canard
comme ça qu'une belle journée c'est
vraiment pas long c'est super agréable
[Musique]
les bienfaiteurs y trouvent leur compte
même si parfois il redonne leur part
comme Sylvie et son fils Patrick est-ce
qu'on en a déjà
c'est une manière aussi de sortir de la
maison et de socialiser dans le partage
et presque tout le temps on est
quasiment tout le temps là
que depuis ce temps-là beaucoup de
tomates l'année passée
beaucoup quand vous êtes beaucoup
mais il y avait plein d'affaires il y
avait des cours il y avait des tomates
j'avais jamais vu de ma vie j'apprends
plein d'affaires
ici les moches sont rois
grosse donc ça durée de vie un peu
dépassée donc moins attirant à l'oeil
mais qui peut se manger de toute façon
là je trouve ça bien ça évite que ce
qu'il y aura pas été cueilli ou ce qui
est moins
beau moins beau mais c'est moins la
forme si on veut donc nous on peut les
ramasser on peut les cueillir puis c'est
ça ça nous aide là ça fait des ça fait
des bons légumes frais
des initiatives de glanage il en existe
une vingtaine au Québec en milieu rural
surtout mais aussi en ville la récolte
de fruits laissés dans les arbres ou
tomber au sol faute de main d'oeuvre ou
de thym fait le bonheur des adeptes du
glamour
en fait c'est bonjour mais les bénévoles
par excellence
dans les locaux de meilleur après on
cuisine une partie de la récolte pour
financer l'organisme que vous allez
vendre ce après
on fait quelques marchés donc c'est
notre façon de s'autofinancer
mais la plus grosse part de son glanage
est redonnée à d'autres organismes de
bienfaisance de la région
Chantal téléphone à la maison puis elle
nous dit j'ai des choses à donner pour
transformer moi je donne ça souvent à
l'école
les personnes
âgées les personnes de HLM personne ça
nous permet de le faire découvrir donc
légumes d'autres façons de présenter les
les repas aussi parce qu'on a quand même
beaucoup d'enfants ça a l'air de rien à
faire on a beaucoup d'enfants puis on
avait des moments qui mangeaient pas
c'était pas riche les frites ça lui
permet de faire des découvertes
culinaires un petit peu différents puis
d'après vous là il y a une vingtaine
d'organismes qui font du gainage au
Québec est-ce que de la place pour en
avoir davantage
il y a encore beaucoup de pertes
[Musique]